morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning toast
it is Monday there is a monsoon there is
a high alert warning for weather and
we're so crazy
we decided finally to take our talents
to zoom honestly we couldn't have chosen
a better day because I'm like so zoomed
friendly these days we had to zoom happy
hours this weekend I'm like okay sure
I'll get back on zoom like zoom is my
work and zoom is my my phone now and I'm
all about the zoom life I know I'm
actually it's so funny cuz like you and
I more you but we both spoke really
negatively about zoom prior to actually
getting on soon and spending some time
here and really is such a user friendly
integrated interface and we love an
integrated interface its user friendly
its podcast friendly it really and it's
like hosting everyone [ __ ] SNL did
their whole episode I was in which we
will talk about we will talk about that
um redheads you zoom for the book club
and if it's good enough for the redheads
it's good enough for the morning toast
so just without anything leaving our
homes today wasn't really an option so
here we are
unzoom finally like everyone else yeah
I'm just feeling so conflicted about the
live show like today I woke up and I
just couldn't do it there's something
about the weather today obviously we
physically cannot walk to our studio
even though it's only a few blocks it's
so crazy outside like it's there's been
like extreme wind alerts there's crazy
rain apparently this afternoon like the
rain is gonna get even crazier and I
just don't want to blow away again I'm
so like thin and small that like I will
that's my fate and that's the price I
have to pay like I will blow away you
run that risk like when you're so thin
so small and you're just walking in a
monsoon and if you're watching our video
portion of this episode you'll notice my
strategically placed microphone and yes
you might say Jackie's not using a
microphone Claudia that is very
unnecessary and it is it is but it
covers my double chin and I didn't put
on any makeup except I've been using my
new tan drops and I I think I look fly
um yeah you know what actually like it
sort of looks like went with combined
with your hair it looks like a big beard
microphone oh I look like a que Ella
settle no 100%
that's your hair behind your Childers
for a second like I think that's better
but I know you love to have your hair in
your face yeah okay well hopefully this
will mean that you guys that we were
able to figure out how to put this video
on YouTube and that you guys are
interested in watching it yeah we're
just gonna we're gonna take the rest of
the week day by day you know we'll see
how the weather is we'll see how I feel
we'll just see how everything is
yes exactly day by day um this weekend
was like so eventful it was not a good
weekend for me like I feel like after
last weekend I was feeling really
positive you know I become really like
the Grinch where he has that whole
schedule with like things that he needs
to do like 6:30 dinner with me I can't
cancel that again but yeah this weekend
like the schedule was just not suffice
in like all of the little menial things
that I do to like keep myself saying
they just they couldn't stack up against
against the demon and me it's so funny
how like sometimes doing something
really dumb like makes you feel
important and then just depending on
your mood mood doing that same thing
like makes you feel dumb I know it's
really crazy
I really have like a good schedule but
on Saturday I was doing my afternoon
reading and I just couldn't maybe
because the book I was reading just
wasn't it you know and I don't have time
for like shitty books right now because
I need to be totally engrossed um but it
was a tough weekend I'm not gonna lie
like I had a few near breakdowns pass
the snitch she's who I call and I just
need to scream into the phone
that's so funny cuz like we're obviously
having like polar opposite weekend's
like last weekend that was it for me
like I was really unwell um but this
weekend I made the great decision to get
like so blackout drunk on Friday night
over a zoom girls night in with you and
if you have our gal pal girl friends
it was so fun it was open we zoomed for
four hours straight yes I do have Jim
premium okay don't ask me for an
autograph
crazy oh my god paparazzi but it was so
fun we played so many games everyone was
drinking laughing being married people
were coming in and out and it was just
it was lit it was lit and we were all
talking about like the plans were gonna
make post the cue and it just like
really it was it was great maybe that
high maybe then on Saturday when I was
like what chillin with my maybe I
couldn't handle the juxtaposition but
Jackie as someone who you
many many times you hate games we played
a bunch of ruins of quick lunch which is
like my favorite I would love to hear
your thoughts I loved it
that's crazy it was my kind of game it
was like every man for himself
your talent will help you through
there's no luck it's not like oh [ __ ] I
got a bad card or I rolled a bad spin
yes you you and your brains and your
weight will get you through or they
won't at all and so there were some
rounds where I was trashed but there
were some rounds where I was a hero I
was actually letting that last night
thinking of some of my best dancers
likes me my most genius ones like
Nintendo 69 that remember that you were
pretty I don't know if you would
remember you know I was so blacked out
you guys and it's because I told
everyone about my Renaissance with white
Claus and as you do with the new
beverage like I've been drinking to heal
in my whole life like I know how much to
drink
how much will get me buzzed how much
will get me blacked out how much will
get me to the point of throwing up and
with white cloud like I just don't know
the statistics yeah like I don't know
the math I haven't like done enough
trial and error so like you said we were
zooming for four [ __ ] hours and I
only really buy the double size white
clause because those little ones are
just like so nonsensical like I can't
get behind it and I had no time for that
yeah right and I had five of the big
double ones which I think it's like 10
white claws which obviously I now
realize is a little too much so I'm just
gonna she could saw her next time you
know you live in your learn yeah you
living you learn but it was a great time
had by all
um and then Saturday what did I do I was
just so busy you know oh you know what I
watched on Saturday I guess we'll talk
about all this in the recaps but I
watched High School Musical the musical
the series Oh Margo has been telling me
about it she says it's bad thoughts a
lot of thoughts will recap them at the
end and then I sent last night at like
12:30 I was like I just want to watch a
movie while I fall asleep so I put on
high school musical and my phone was
like charging and I didn't pick up my
phone once and I was so engrossed in it
and this such a good movie and I have so
many thoughts like I I have so many
thoughts and it will recap them at the
end of the show plus little pie is
everywhere right I didn't really get to
branch out this weekend because I
watched little fires everywhere which
I'm starting to absolutely hate and then
I just spent the rest of the weekend
with been watching One Tree Hill and I'm
just like so in love with the show like
and I wish that you were on this journey
with me I keep trying to beg snitch I'm
like this is Margo's type of show I'm
like Margo 80 people in high school
being cringy like that is you
in the genre like why wasn't she's just
so stubborn she like feels like she
would be betraying Marissa Cooper and
the OSI if she started to watch One Tree
Hill and I'm just like Margo that's
nothing of the sort but she just refuses
to get on board she's so stubborn like
it's it's not worth your time to try and
convert a stubborn person into a non
stubborn she's so stubborn like I'm a
lot of crazy stubborn like I can't no I
I can't talk to someone who's just like
so she's like a brick wall like has a
mind made up about stuff like
arbitrarily what it is I have like
things like I'm stubborn about like
random things like you can't get me they
think otherwise but like her whole being
is just like being stubborn mm-hmm it's
true that's why she you know founded a
company called StubHub and they sell
tickets to concerts
she is dubbed oh she really is okay I
think it's time to just get right into
it because mostly because I just want to
recap all the TV and stuff that I
watched so let's hit it with the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and that's true Jackie but you know
Jackie you and I are a lot of things and
one of those things is definitely like
fashion icons fashionistas yeah I would
say we're quite fashion-forward yeah and
that's my passion for fashion
that's why it's so pertinent that
today's episode is brought to you by
making the cut the new Amazon series
hosted by fashions favorite duo Heidi
Klum and Tim Gunn Amazon's new original
series making the cut assembles twelve
talented design entrepreneurs from
around the world to compete for the
chance to turn their brands into the
next global fashion business Naomi
Campbell nicole richie joseph al jazeera
kareem right field and Kiara frog may
join Heidi Klum and Tim as judges
challenges will take designers from New
York to Paris to Tokyo winning looks
will meet will winning looks for making
the cut will be available on Amazon in
the making the cuts store immediately
following each episode watch making the
cut now new episodes each Friday only on
prime video love it that sounds so good
I can't wait to watch I know what a star
set it ensemble uh judges and my guests
yeah totally
okay
ready for our first story because um
something we talked about last week we
were really looking forward to it I
managed to watch half of it and it was
just not at this Tom Hanks host SNL from
home in the show's first remote episode
SNL emerge from the pandemic quarantine
ashes with a fresh if unconventional
episode Saturday night including a cold
opening zoom montage with cast members
phoning it in from their own kitchens
and living rooms quote it's Saturday
Night Live at home the announcer shouted
before introducing as the evenings host
actor and recently recovered
Cobin 19 patient Tom Hanks I mean I mean
what you didn't okay I didn't but then I
was like you know we talked about it so
much on the show I want to come back
with with my thoughts and I really
watched it with like an open heart and
open mind because I'm like I don't know
mostly because of Michael try and I
didn't even make it to Weekend Update
now that I think about it um and it was
just like not it and you know what I
mean think I'm so I guess all of the
most they did some zoom sketches or just
one that I saw but really it was like
the people the comedian's where like had
an idea for a sketch and they filled
with themselves with whoever their
quarantine II was you know kind of like
a youtuber might it's really not that
like an iPhone whatever they had at home
so you can't really tell the difference
between an iPhone and a camera SD
sometimes you know like we do all of our
um vlogs on an iPhone but they look the
same as people who do them so it doesn't
matter the quality was fine but it was
like the ideas they would have been
better off like going out to a few
youtubers who do comedy sketches and
been like hey can you come up with some
funny cuz these people like it made me
feel like they're just so old like they
couldn't think of how to do a funny
comedy sketch on in a vlog you know and
that's really all it was they need a
parody it was a YouTube video parody
like hey wait it's not that foreign of a
concept it's not like they were you know
doing all these sketches where they one
person filmed one thing from somewhere
like Pete Davidson did a sketch
pretending to be Drake's music video
like in his house
you know right foot left foot side and
it was just like Pete Davidson in his
mom's basement which you think would be
a kind of okay that's a good idea let's
go with it and it was trash it was
absolutely
and then uh kate mckinnon did like Ruth
Bader Ginsburg workout at home good idea
right like she's doing a home at home
workout good idea as far as ice and all
those and it was just like not well
executed they needed king batch know
exactly they needed like david dobrik
this really was a missed opportunity for
them to call on digital creators and
comedians and really like blend those
two worlds because these people just
like I hate to say it because I'm old
too but like they're too old to be
making digital content on their phones
from their homes well what's so
interesting is that I feel like if I'm
ever home on a Saturday night and I like
forget that SNL is on like I'll be
scrolling Twitter or Facebook like I'll
always remember that it's on and I'll
always like watch it because I record it
and with this episode I legitimately
until you just mention this first story
I haven't heard anything about it I
totally forgot I planned on watching it
I was home on Saturday night yeah well I
mean you know time and days are just a
social contract so you wouldn't have
that Saturday night feeling of like oh
maybe Saturday Night Live also I don't
think you heard anything about it cuz
even if as I was looking for an article
about it today um no no one refuses to
say anything negative about it you know
like no one they're just sort of quoting
everything that happened explaining and
then there's no like take like this was
a dumpster fire I think because
everyone's just trying to be nice and
this is me being negative because I I'm
very open they're doing it again next
week like this is gonna be the new thing
and I feel like they should finally
embrace the digital comedy community and
and make some magic happen this is a
great opportunity like it doesn't have
to be decided I do want to find a way to
watch Weekend Update but the episode was
starting to make me so depressed like
totally depressed like depressed for the
state of the world like depressed about
coronavirus like the whole thing it was
bad to the bone oh that's so
disappointing I feel sad for everyone I
thought that they were doing a good job
you know I don't understand like in the
current climate why certain shows just
like won't go on hiatus you know it's
like during the regular season like they
take vacations they take weeks off but
like for some reason certain shows are
having a really hard time letting go and
like insisting on doing shows from home
with their like spotty Wi-Fi connection
and it's just like take a break
I think it's more that they have the ads
like sold I mean I think they probably
have like very similar reasons as we do
we're a business and I think people did
take about a month off what we're now on
like day 32 of the queue and it's like
if we're gonna if this is gonna be more
months then you have to figure out a way
to work from home yeah but like or I
need to know like are people watching
Jimmy Fallon from home are people
watching watchstrap inside from home
like I'm Andy's number one fan I haven't
even turned it on once no I don't have
no idea what how coasters will have to
let us know but I do I mean I feel like
if people did take that hiatus and now
they're trying to make it work like SNL
they were gone for a month and now about
trying to make it work and it just it
didn't work they even have like a what
should have been the easiest one zoom
sketch of a workplace first zoom call
you know everyone's getting situated not
it not it's just also like because they
don't do they are not on those calls
right there aren't real people on zooms
trying to communicate about the 4th
quarterly earnings right they're not
like real people who's like spouse is on
a Zune call and it's Friday at 5:30 p.m.
and wife is in the kitchen over
listening over eavesdropping and hearing
that her husband is the one who is
extending the 5:30 p.m. Friday zoom call
and that get her now her crossed to
there no none of them have ever like
looked up from their couch and realized
that their husband is the person who
uses the word id8
literally once every call he's okay
let's set up some time to id8 after this
I'm like I D eight yeah and you didn't
just say that like that's not even a
word
I mean it is technically in like the biz
world what a brainstorm yes it is a
brainstorm but that I think what
happened was that word just got to like
overused you know I'm I'm in this I
don't think you could use the word
brainstorm the only part of this SNL
that I saw that I liked was the intro
where is everyone like from home and
then they put it over the SNL music and
I guess the editor did a good job Colin
Jost was looking fine he's been growing
out his beard and he has gray in his
beard that's what I saw
and I mean I need to watch Weekend
Update now because I need to see Michael
che a precious gem of man and I need to
see Colin Jost
hottest gem of man this is what we need
certain SNL stars like are married to
famous people like I need those famous
people to be in the kitchen like I need
a sketch of Colin and Scarlett like
Scarlett's on her zoom Collins on his
and like they keep getting in each
other's maybe because they live in like
a small apartment like that's when I
need I need them to really lean into all
their resources like as anyone else if
Pete Davidson is like hooking up with
some girl like I need her yeah I don't
think that he is from his mom's basement
though but like I want to see Pete
David's mom Dave's his mom what does the
rest of the house look like you know
what do you hide quarantine in your
mom's basement Netflix did like in
promotion with his comedy special they
did like a YouTube video which was a
tour of like his underground basement
that he had like built out because he's
like so rich he had it like built out
like a rapper but it's like in his mom
Staten Island apartment it was actually
really funny that is funny I do really
like him but it was just it was making
me feel like like the production company
that did Rebecca Black Friday like
showed up to his house to film him like
pretending to be Drake I don't know did
it appear like they had people come to
these people's houses to like help them
with attack no not for one [ __ ]
second it's not that look but I don't
know why they couldn't you know like
even I saw Morgan Stewart Knightley pop
is coming back tonight nice on her story
that she had like people in where she's
staying like setting up so that it could
like look good
yeah I saw Tonya rad had like radio
people come set up the radio stuff in
her apartment like it's doable it's
doable
you can be like you can wear protective
gear it is very beautiful
so it was around maybe they'll they'll
learn from their tech errors and maybe
next week we'll have a little bit more
of like a high-end moment we'll see we
have to see if Lauren and the crew learn
from their mistakes here's the thing it
wasn't even the tech like I could get
people are getting so used to watching
like shitty tech listening to zoom
podcasts like the tech we can forgive it
was the humor like they couldn't there's
so much to joke about like there's so
much going on and they couldn't hit they
couldn't hit it because no me it's her
ball that's turn yeah very sad but our
next stories little
positive news of entertainers coming
together Andrea Bocelli performs live
from Milan Cathedral on Easter Sunday I
am Catholic he has risen she has risen
it was so beautiful like I don't know if
you guys know this but actually my time
up this week I was immediately
transported back to my trip to feed NZ
which is um Florence in French if you
don't know oh no I'm like just feel
really connected to this city especially
that Duomo which is you know at the city
center it's like beautiful cathedral and
the seeing is how I spent you know like
four days like a lot of time there
I feel really deeply connected to like
the entire culture and just like the
Duomo in general like you know we walked
up the steps I actually only got halfway
and then I met my friends back down at
the bottom I was just over it but this
video was like really particularly
inspiring to me because I am like a
Italian like enthusiastic you were
pretty much like born in Firenze
yeah I'm whatever they look it I'm the
equivalent of like a Francophile in
Italian Italian file that's what I am so
this was deeply moving during the music
for hope concert which was live
streaming worldwide the opera singer
performed iconic religious songs such as
Ave Maria and Sancta Maria okay so
here's the thing the thing is this is
exactly what we need this is exactly
something negative this is exactly how
it's done
you know and it shows you it shows you
that it can be done right tech wise
talent wise performance wise all levels
this has achieved greatness
I feel like this pandemic is really
separating like the boys from the men in
terms of talent and you know what I was
realizing as I'm as we're starting to
get deeper and deeper into like
celebrities losing their minds and
influencers it's like it's not the
celebrities who I don't want to hear
from it's actors and actresses you know
I want to hear from comedians I want to
hear from artists you know I want to
hear from but like people who act and
they're not acting right now like and
it's just not your time there are two
totally not even two there's like four
different subgroups in Hollywood and I
agree there certain people I definitely
want to hear from there's something
about like
really really rich community instead to
me like I don't get jealous up like
really really rich actors are like to me
so out of touch but really really rich
comedians who's like job it is to like
be aware of like what's going on in the
world to me like there's less a
resentment from me towards like comedian
worth you know Jerry Seinfeld worth one
hundred million dollars and like
Leonardo DiCaprio like there's a
difference to me yeah there's also a
difference I feel between like Chris
Martin who's just like a super talented
artist like I would like to hear from
him versus George Clooney I don't want
to hear from him I don't like he's not
he's not in a movie right now I'm yeah
and it's like certain celebrities talent
like will will make meaningful like the
comedy that comes out of this like he's
important like the art the music the
like that stuff like is tangible
you know ya know and it's healing stuff
and eventually when we make a movie
about it like you actors and actresses
can go [ __ ] and and you know anyone and
everything comes back like well watch
your TV shows again but as far as being
like human beings we don't know you as
human beings we know you it's the actor
it got you played you know yeah and I
therefore I don't want to hear from you
yeah and I feel like you and I
we're like having this feeling of like
resentment and like just like general
disinterest in celebrity culture like
when this all started and it's just so
funny how everyone is really really
feeling that way and like people are
writing articles about it like there's
definitely like this communal
disinterest in this like once important
social construct yes I totally agree and
every time I read an article like that
I'm just so glad that I'm not the only
one feeling this way and even though
there's still something about it that
like I can't explain because it's
different for every single celebrity
it's different for influencers it's
different for comedians it's different
from artists like when Luke home says
he's going live I'm like where we meet
we ride at dawn but when you're [ __ ]
Miley Cyrus is doing another live like I
there's no rhyme or reason to why
something makes me so angry versus like
so inspired no that's so true but I
think that these articles like that New
York Times article in particular are
just so helpful in putting into words
like what I'm feeling
yes I totally agree but I'm so glad
that entrepot tally was able to show up
and show out and show everyone else how
it's done and that it can be done and
that there's just like no excuse for the
mediocre content yeah and I'm not sure
if you are like familiar with what the
Duomo is usually like but like I said I
did spend a lot of time there um it's
actually it's like Times Square like
literally there's a million people like
if you ever wants to take a picture in
front of it there's 7,000 people in your
picture so it was also really really
cool to see like nobody there it's like
seeing Times Square completely I'm Jay
that is really crazy that is beautiful
and my love of Italy is just booming
booming love that for you okay well I
have my next story is like a little
spooky positive news wait but it might
be a boy honey
of course it was bye honey honey only
brings us positive news thank God
cuz we all shop a lot shop online a lot
especially me these days but did you
know that you can make online shopping
even easier and better with honey the
free online shopping tool that saves you
money online
honey automatically finds the best promo
codes and applies them to your cart
which makes online shopping feel as easy
as it's supposed to be imagine you're
shopping at one of your favorite sites
Target Best Buy Sephora Macy's eBay Etsy
Walmart anything when you check out a
little box drops down and all you have
to do is click apply coupons wait a few
seconds for it to scan every promo code
code on the internet and watch the
prices drop I have shopped pretty much
everywhere and sometimes I'm like do I
forget that I have the honey extension
and I'm just like shopping at ASOS you
want to say I'm like yeah I do honey
show me the money
it's just everything of a store it's so
easy to download the toasters tell me
about it long before honey was a sponsor
but now that they are I just like want
everyone to know about it it's so
fabulous you save so much money yeah
it's amazing they found over honey they
have found over 18 million members over
two billion dollars in savings
honey supports over 30,000 stores online
and they're adding new ones every day
their users love it that's why it has
over a hundred thousand five-star
reviews on the Google Chrome storm if
you're not using honey you're literally
passing up a free money it's free to use
and installs in just a few seconds plus
it's backed by PayPal so you know that
it's good get honey for free at join
honey dot-com slash toast that's join
honey calm slash toas tea join honey
calm slash toast
save yourself some cash
because what I'll see you doing right
now yeah okay first third story spooky
positive news one direction members Reef
a Lowe's a Malik on Twitter sparking
reunion buzz why reunion buzz is sparked
the former members of 1d are giving fans
hope in quarantine with the Brit boy
bands 10th anniversary coming up July
23rd devoted followers have noticed that
Harry Liam Louis and Niall have all
Rafal insane on Twitter although he has
not followed them back what I mean it's
always been my understanding that when
it's not an if but at when one direction
comes back together it would be without
saying yeah um it's been my
understanding that that that Zayn
wouldn't stop them like that Zayn would
it wouldn't matter it seems in were out
like if he wants me in it'll be the five
but if he goes back to being you know
like his bad to the bone like I've been
too cool for school cuz I'm too cool to
you should record a cover up that song
to you I love that son yeah it's like he
he can come if you want you know if he
wants a bit like the reunion will not be
stymied by his absence or lack thereof
well this story is both like upsetting
and not upsetting because obviously it's
making me realize like we might be
getting one step closer to a reunion and
as a one day stand like that's truly all
you could hope for but to be honest like
I don't really want Zayn a part of the
man like to me when I think of One
Direction like I think of them as the
for like I think the last album they
released was the best one I think Zayn
bought this like toxic energy and I
think they were all really really good
friends like without him so I'm really
okay to move on without him Luke Hayden
move on without him but I mean to get
the thigh you know they are the thighs
like even though the four and the album
without saying was amazing also the
album's with the same are amazing so I
think if we could go all in that would
obviously be so so great in iconic and
it would show that they've all made up I
don't think sane would you
anything I see doesn't want to do and
like I'm Damien's talented and I'm here
for Zayn I'm also here for knows a time
I'll take whatever I could get you know
I'll take whatever I can get but I just
want to say like the four of him coming
together would be just as maybe more
iconic than the five like I don't
consider the element of special it
couldn't be more iconic than the part I
think that it would be like I love that
he left and nobody cared no shame and
like it just showed that he wasn't what
was making the band so great I'm sure he
thought that he was because the last
album was the best album you know I'm
sure that that's what it part of it was
that like he thought he was better than
everyone and like he liked Camila kibale
like going out but like Camila kibale
actually was better than everyone and
you could see they're all their solo
careers like who's who's on Dancing with
the Stars and like who's at the Grammys
like she really was elevated from the
group um yeah but the group also was was
like they were finding the counter they
put out music without her and it was
like good stuff Oh completely irrelevant
like when she was on because they
disbanded after that but like if they
had kept going they would have been like
our token girl band and Camila would
have been a solo artist and we would
have ever forgotten that they were all
together at one point yeah you know for
the sake of like you know Dinah Jane I
really felt like they should have stayed
together but normani is having like a
moment too so she'll be up there with
Camila soon even though she like never
release his music but she's somehow like
the next beyoncé when she's released two
songs she and I hey great I'm just
saying she's literally released like no
music and before she even released
motivation which is fabulous people were
like she's an ex-fiance I'm like Beyonce
releases music and like I haven't heard
anything from nor money except for that
song with Khaled tell me and it's like
it's like when there's you know a new
startup in town it's like they haven't
even sold anything yet but you just know
this is the next billion dollar company
and yo invest and that's we're worth
money of course I'm just saying like
it's important to point out that she's
an ex-fiance who's on a really these two
songs when she's the next cuz she
couldn't she's on her way things Beyonce
for like two years like I've been
talking about this for a while and she's
been release more than two songs popular
songs I don't know
he has released she was on a Sam Smith
song it's really motivation that's like
the big song right now
and by the way it's you fabulous slow
and steady wins the race okay
not today but all I'm saying is like the
band really should have stayed together
for the likes of Ally Brooke Lauren her
eggy and Dinah Jane um no that's exactly
why I shouldn't have stayed together
yeah I know
but you know it's like it's funny how
both one direction and fifth harmony
came out of shark or not Shark Tank
x-factor and like honestly I really feel
like this harmony was put together
poorly like I mean look about you should
have been made it as a solo act maybe
she didn't do a good job at like
Hollywood boot camp but like there was a
huge disparity in the group whereas I
feel like with one direction and you
could see like based on what's happening
in all their solo careers like they
really all were equally talented no they
weren't
there's a difference between how hairy
and and Lois you're a wizard Harry
there's a difference okay anyways we
could argue about this silver blue in
the face that I'm ready to move on
because page six has an exclusive that
the rouhani cast members and producers
are livid over jabs from Bethenny
Frankel have you seen this I have
Bethenny Frankel may have gone too far
this time we're told the cast including
some of her longtime pals and supporters
art and top producers on Real Housewives
of New York are furious with their
former colleague after she took a cheap
shot about them about the show's ratings
during a TV interview she said on extra
quote the ratings overall in television
have never been higher and perhaps the
ratings on Real Housewives aren't doing
well because it's sort of not maybe the
content that it's inspiring people to do
what they need to do right now the dig
was met with why with immediate and
widespread outrage even by some of her
loyal allies no I'm sorry I totally
agree like what she's saying is like
this is this ragtag group of women like
none of them really have any money
they're all downsizing like this is
supposed to be an aspirational show and
meanwhile everyone's broker than the
next oh I don't even think she means is
that they're broke I think it's like
we're in a [ __ ] pandemic it's just
you know this lazy Real Housewives
content isn't gonna cut it
and I think when Beverly Hills premieres
they're gonna have seller ratings
because it's just gonna be a stellar
season and I think what she's saying is
that roni as it is right now is just not
stellar she look I'm
she's digging at Ramona and LuAnn and
Dorinda and Sonja who think that like
they just show up in the show is great
but like they're not exuding greatness
and right now as a people we need
greatness
therefore we need Erica Jean and her
looks we need Lisa Rinna dancing we need
Doreen and her barrettes and by the way
when we recap Real Housewives of New
York this is the exact sentiment that we
share it's like it's just not good
enough like especially during quarantine
times but just in general like Real
Housewives has a very high standard for
entertainment and currently New York is
not meeting that standard yeah
especially during a time when everyone
is watching TV all we want is new
content and like you know what if we
didn't do the morning toast every day I
probably wouldn't be keeping up
week-to-week with Ronan right now I
probably wait till the end of the season
and catch up and like when I love a show
I need it immediately so I totally agree
with Bethenny I don't even think that's
a date I think that straight facts
ratings are high for everything and it's
not high for roni think about it yeah
like you know what even New Jersey which
has been like a real like slacker in the
Housewives franchise like even this
season was pretty good like I would say
that this most recent season is giving
me better vibes than the one that we're
watching on New York like and a good
spot what to be fair it's only been two
episodes of New York but I think like we
can it's hard to judge a season two
episodes in when really nothing happens
for a while
yeah B you just get the vibe that
everyone's phoning it in like especially
the OGS like they just feel entitled to
some respect because they've been on
show on TV for so long like you still
have to entertain me yeah I agree with
that okay it and final story a little
business and it's really just you know
some biz leaders news Walmart CEO says
we're in the quote haircolor phase of
panic buying this is really funny
first once the hand sanitizer
disinfectants and toilet paper now hair
clippers and hair dye are flying off the
shelves in recent weeks Americans
shopping powders are serving as a
reflection of how the corona virus
pandemic continues to evolve and affect
daily lives you can definitely see that
as people have stayed home their focus
has shifted the Walmart CEO Doug
McMillon said on The Today Show after
stocking up on food and consumable
products choppers turned to puzzles
games and other timeless forms of
entertainment as well as
education he said now sales are showing
that without the ability to venture to a
hair salon folks are getting shaggy
people are starting to need a haircut he
said you see more beard trimmers and
hair color and things like that it's
interesting to watch a dynamic layout
that is so funny because I literally
bought a hair trimmer yesterday I bought
a like hair trimmer I have pair of hair
scissors for my eyebrows but if you have
a tik-tok this comes as no surprise like
kids are bleaching their hair they're
giving themselves bangs like their
coloring their hair they're dying parts
of their hair because it's obviously for
necessity because no one's able to get
their hair cut but it's also just out of
straight bored I'm like I literally
thought about giving myself bangs I
thought about shaving my head wow I
don't understand like I'm bored I'm
gonna cut bangs like I don't understand
that as much it's like I need a haircut
you know I got a haircut right before
the cue luckily because I kind of had
one since June and if I hadn't gotten
that haircut in I swear I would have
been cutting my own hair because my hair
was so dead with the with that boredom
thing it's first of all cutting your
bangs like gives you like something to
do like you would film it it takes like
an hour like to really perfect it so
you're not only getting an activity but
then you were like a new lease on life
like you know in the real world if
you're like a new bag or new haircut
like you're it's like literally your
whole life like it's in all your
pictures like you just care so much
about it and ink party and I feel like
it would make you feel if you liked it
it would make you feel like even more
excited than you would normally with a
new haircut like you would FaceTime all
your friends like it would just give you
stuff to do and it would be like a
something different okay I think you
should do it no I know I'm not I
literally um I don't think I could pull
off bangs I would love to I was actually
talking about with you a few days ago
like I think I want to dye my hair
blonde do it like how do I do it I can't
see one reason I shouldn't that's what
I'm saying
oh but you know I'm not relying is my
husband is growing a full beard and you
know some men like Zack Shapiro our
brother-in-law some men like have the
face for beard and they have the hair
follicles for beard like it grows in
thick and you look like you live in
Brooklyn but some men don't have that
like been never really has grown a beard
in his life and it's coming in like very
rabbinical you know it's like very curly
and like kind of patchy and like no
offense to the rabbi community but
that's just like the type of you know
beard unless you're like a very high
ranking rabbi like the global rabbi of
Israel or something like then you
yeah Rabbinical you know beards are kind
of like pubie like they're patchy and
they're a little curly and that's what's
coming through my husband and like I
don't know how to tell I'm like I don't
even want to kiss him
you should just when he's sleeping shave
his face like it'd be so upset like he
talks about this beard no but you got
but you could be like oh my god there's
a ghost you know like something crazy
and maybe you shave off like a little
bit of your eyebrows so that like you
look like you got certain you got like
hit with it - absolutely you know
Oh cut off like a little of your hair
though you have to do yourself too so
that he thinks you've both got hit by
the ghost I'll shave my mustache great
no it's just cheaper faces it's becoming
like a weapon to like last night before
bad like I gave him a hug and he like he
kissed me on the scratchy
my under I like got scratch with these
pew be like beard hairs and it was I
literally couldn't add water coming out
of my abs being a little dramatic but
it's really becoming dangerous now no
it's it's also a nice exfoliant it's
really crazy though
um the insert that's a crazy thing and I
just feel like unless you married a man
with a beard and you're like I'm a beard
woman like then I'm interested but you
don't just like four years into marriage
become a beard guy when your wife never
said that she was a beard woman yeah
it's almost deceptive to just become a
totally different person that would be
like it's I just like decided to change
my name like I want to be Julian it
would be like if you just decided to
become blonde but you know you should
maybe you should to show him no that
would be like if I started dating Ben
and I had a bald vagina and then one day
I'm like you know what I want a bush
yeah you want a bush for sure I mean now
you don't have a choice so it'll be
goddess Bush yeah but she vibes it's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] vibe Bush's baked beans oh
can I show everyone who's watching at
home the video something I have I have a
surprise like you can make it Premium
okay oh is it
Theodore faction man faction was he like
freaking out that he wasn't going to
work today oh my god he looks like not
well think about
oh my god what is going on I'm gonna buy
is he feeling this way hi can you oh hi
angel muffin man hi cutie patootie
loving boy beautiful boy why not what's
he disturbed why is he so [ __ ]
lethargic um he went on a crazy walk
today in the rain and when he goes out
in the rain he decides like he's not
gonna poop for an hour so no way you
think God it wasn't me he was walking it
was Ben he's just tired but he's so
perfect literally this weekend was like
so special for us oh that's so sweet
he's so perfect was he like curious why
he wasn't coming into work today to be
the head of culture of tea nn-no he
could tell like by the weather that it
was just not safe conditions for anyone
totally agree also the winds are so loud
you would probably hear them in our
studio because our windows are
paper-thin also in my bedroom the
windows in my bedroom like aren't Center
facing like they don't look at the
street they look at the backs of other
buildings so it becomes like a wind
tunnel and I'm up all night it's so
scary literally everything shakes and it
happens like even when it's just normal
weather but last night was so scary
and I watched like three scary ass
episodes of One Tree Hill spoiler alert
there was a whole episode with like a
school shooting and it was so scary and
then at midnight when Ben goes to walk
vo I get left in the apartment alone and
like I never have really been scared but
I was like freaked out after the episode
of Jimmy Edwards shooting up the school
so like I was freaking out like
literally I made Margo FaceTime me just
so I would like have someone to talk to
in case like Dan Scott came in and shot
me do you get to the episode yet no okay
it's but somebody hangs it on the live
stream they're like because it's the
most ridiculous premise I've ever heard
and I'm really excited for when you get
there because it seems ridiculous okay I
haven't heard anything about the dog but
you know what you would find really
interesting is that the show was
actually like really integrated with
like early 2000s music so obviously
Gavin DeGraw is the theme song but like
he accidentally like walked into the
cafe one time and then ended up playing
a song show a crow has been on Fall Out
Boy Jimmy Eat World like they were
obviously like a music show it was
really but in the part that I'm up to
Pete Wentz is like a full-blown cast
mate
he starts dating one of the girls
interests and he's a terrible actor
that's weird
okay let's get into all of our recaps
because I have so much to talk about I
want to talk about little fires
everywhere and High School Musical the
musical the series sure um it's okay if
I just let you know that this entire
recap segment is brought to you by
Beachbody on demand please it comes as
no surprise that we're all stuck in our
homes for a while so avoid the
complacency it's important now more than
ever to keep active and keep moving work
out and take classes in the comfort of
your own home with Beachbody on demand
it's easy to use streaming service that
gives you instant access to over 1,300
super effective workouts suited for
anybody at any time the secret to
getting results is just getting started
this is a company behind p90x insanity
and 21 day fix now check out some of the
beach bodies newer programs like morning
meltdown 180 day obsession and start
strong they have some of the best
trainers you can get motivated by
celebrity super trainers you know like
10 Tony Horton Joel Freeman Jerry komak
Matthews and autumn Calabrese on they
have some of the best programs where you
can workout on your own schedule as
short as 10 minutes that don't require
extra equipment that's the thing it's
like people are now starting to work
from home and let you put on a workout
that needs like a foam roller who the
hell has that no today I'm actually in
my home office slash gym I have my
little workout mat behind me and that's
where I hit a beach body you can access
that workouts anywhere anytime on your
computer web enabled enabled TV tablet
smartphone Roku Apple TV chromecast and
more we love an accessible platform and
it's the best deal in Fitness because
listeners of the morning toast can try
it absolutely free we've really enjoyed
you know after doing the morning toast
we do the morning melt down 100 so it's
nice to have schedule especially in
corrent like you do any morning shows
then the morning meltdown and then you
have your meltdown and then you get back
to work yeah and then it's 6:30 dinner
with me you can cancel that again you
have got to try out Beachbody right now
our listeners can get a special free
trial membership when you text toast to
30 30 30 you'll get full access to the
entire platform for free all the
workouts the nutritional information and
support totally free again just text
toast
toas t2 30 30 30 3-0 3-0 3-0 text toast
- 30 30 30
thank you Beachbody on demand from open
it up
love it sign on get your bod right all
right let's do the choice of the weekend
which was little fires everywhere I
hadn't seen the most recent two episodes
and I accidentally watched them out of
order what you think would be like messy
but it didn't really make a difference
yeah because it was all flashbacks so it
didn't really I had the choice to play
annasophia robb as early Reese
Witherspoon was absolutely inspiring it
and the actress who played early Kerry
Washington
she obviously studied the way Kerry
Washington talks in acts because she
nailed her nails yes I I like thought
that they were maybe morphing Kerry
Washington's voice with this girl's
voice because it was so similar yeah I
thought so too
um okay I have a lot to tell you about
how it differs from the book because
there are some major differences that I
think you would like be very interested
by first of all the surrogate I mean
this isn't a difference but were you
shook about the surrogate thing
oh yeah and honestly like it all makes
sense as to why she's like helping this
random woman find her baby right and why
she's constantly on the run because
she's technically like kidnapped these
people's child and that's why she also
loves pearl so much and wants to protect
her so it makes you understand why she
is the way that she is but it also makes
you hate her you have like what she did
was awful like she stole their baby
yeah well it's like it was because it
was like she injected his semen into her
it is 50% like her DNA so she does feel
like the mother so she does feel like
the mother which is why she identifies
with baby
um but obviously she wouldn't have this
child it's Jesse Williams didn't give it
to her
no and didn't pay her it's really I
could get that biologically it's her
baby but like they had a full legal
agreement they had paperwork drawn up
like she gave up the rights and honestly
I don't take her side or BB side like
you gave up the baby someone else like I
just don't agree yeah I I agree with you
also okay Karen that situation I know I
I mean I'm sure that it's tough but like
oh my god I was talking with my friends
last night about the show and there's
one line that Kerry Washington says it
just has really stuck with me that I
just think it's so profound and I don't
think it was in the book when she says I
was in like the knot bees two episodes
the one before when she says to Elena
like you didn't make good choices you
had good choices I just think that's so
like apt because people are always like
holier than thou like oh I wouldn't have
found myself in that situation it's like
you like just life is so different for
everyone and I just think that that was
like the most poignant way and I don't
think it was from the book so whoever
wrote that line just like summed up
privilege in one fell swoop and I just
feel really has stuck with me totally
but watching Mia's like coming-of-age
story it does seem like she had better
choices than the one that she made well
yes I agree but here's the biggest
difference is that Mia and the artist
the photographer Pro Lena Pauline they
weren't lovers at all pulling the bone
in the book Pauline had a partner and a
girlfriend and Mia used to go to their
house and have dinner with them and
sometimes like stay with them and they
really like looked after her in New York
but they weren't lovers because in the
in the show now the fact that there are
a couple it's like why couldn't even the
$12,000 from your girlfriend who's so
rich oh and also that entire
relationship was so inappropriate like
she was her student she was giving
appropriate acts like it was so
inappropriate and I think that was never
like honestly I felt bad for me it was
like she was being taken advantage of by
someone older than her a hundred percent
but that wasn't part of the book at all
like their relationship was only like
you know big sister little sister like
mentoring and being helpful and so I
just don't understand why they put that
in there because it just confuses a
storyline it also makes it like oh she
why didn't she just get money from her
right and so when her financial aid was
taken away I just felt like there was
other things she could have looked into
like I don't know a job or in the book
in the book in the book she already had
three jobs okay okay
like waitressing working at an art store
and there was something else that she
was doing like she couldn't take on one
more thing okay because in the series
they just made it seem like oh I need
money let me give me someone a baby like
she didn't even think through asking her
parents asking her lover getting a job
like it was just easy money and then
like stealing these people's babies yes
no I totally
agree but in the book they do a better
job of showing that she did not have any
choices and expenses because Pauline
wasn't her lover she was just her
teacher right so you're not gonna answer
a teacher for $12,000
right the guy who played um Reese
Witherspoon's a younger lover like in
Paris was it the same actor playing him
young and playing him old I don't know
they looked so alike though they did
such a good job with the castings it was
crazy and then I was like why can't
Reese Witherspoon play young but the man
can play young you know I don't think it
was the same actor I really don't know
so it was like because even Reese's
husband they've got different actors
they got different actors for the
mcculloch I don't think they would have
just gotten used the same actor for
Jamie and again Jamie the story in the
book they never had an affair or
anything like that Jamie was just like
decided she dated in high school or
college who like wanting he wound up
like moving to San Francisco's I mean he
was just kind of like more arts here and
free-spirited and she chose she did not
choose that life and it's always been
like you know that she resents Mia
because Mia is that way and maybe if
Reese had chosen that life she would
live differently but she never goes to
him and says she's miserable like she's
very like upset in her life so they
never having it there she never goes to
New York to see him like it's just
always the sting in the back of her head
like oh I could have had a different
life but I didn't ya know her life is
good I just um with the with the New
York thing it's like
I'm sorry I don't remember it I was
gonna say I was just like talking hoping
something would come to the front of my
brain but it never did do you think that
well actually you know what's gonna
happen so I don't want to know but was
that like Reese Witherspoon through her
investigating is gonna like find Jesse
Williams hmm okay don't tell me okay
no but it's like that scene where she
finds out she's pregnant I guess they're
setting up that like she really does
hate is he even though like watching her
as a mom like I just feel like she's
being a good mom like I don't really
feel like she hates her kid even though
is he feels like she does but it seems
like she never wanted is he like is he
was the problem child is he drove her to
have the affair like there's some like
hatred of Izzy underlying in the book do
you want to know what it is I can't
remember if she did want a fourth child
or not but it didn't matter she had all
easy pregnancies with her first three
and then with Izzy was the most
problematic pregnancy like every it was
just the most nerve-racking one is he
was I born early she was in um and I see
you as a baby like she wasn't like she
had just all these different issues and
Reese was always worried about her so
she was always like is he don't do this
is he don't do that because she like
wanted to keep her healthy and then it
turned into this relationship of her
always having to like is he is he cuz
like she was trying to look out for her
you know yeah by the way we totally ship
pearl and trip of course so cute but the
whole abortion thing was really really
sad especially when she went to Mia's
house and Mia was being really mean to a
little girl who just had an abortion in
the book Mia is so welcoming like
doesn't throw anything in her face
telling her to wash her mug and like
just reminding her that she's a bad
person like okay maybe she's not the
most gracious person but like she this
isn't the time to tell her that you know
yeah he's only hysterically crying it
was so painful and I just don't want to
know why they're making Mia even more
unlikable when she's already like a
character she might not be she's
obviously not your favorite but some
people I could identify with her she's
artsy she's free-spirited she's
strong-willed she's like you know she's
a good mom in the book in the series
she's just so mean yeah and you know at
first I thought that when she needed
money for BB's legal fees she sold that
piece of art that was above her mantle
but she didn't she's pulled that picture
that
Pauline took of her so she's literally
taking someone else's work and taking
money for it but I just probably gave
her those pictures so that she would
have money when she needed it also I
feel like if I didn't read the book I
would have no [ __ ] clue what was
going on like all that stuff with
Pauline and duo and like the picture I
would have just been so confused over so
many like small things that they said
like fairly that you had to pick up on
or else I would not know what's going on
right because where I'm getting confused
is that Mia
according to Izzy Mia is this like
world-renowned artist when she literally
went to school for a year and then like
I guess I get that school doesn't make
you an artist but like what credentials
make her this world-renowned artist so
she's not world-renowned but she's very
talented so when she makes something
she's able to sell it it does well
because it's a good piece of art but
she's not Pauline but she is talented
and I think maybe if she lived in New
York and she ran in those circles she
could become like a big artist but
because she wants to live in anima Slee
like her work speaks for itself and
there it's just like no artist behind
the work taught it okay
yeah like such a liking to her cuz she
really is really talented I'm just like
not liking the series as much as I was
when it started
no because it's there just I don't know
I'm not like like I'm not liking it
either I barely liked the book but it's
like even worse than the book somehow
because they're adding on all these
elements to make the characters like
more unsympathetic when like you if I
just saw the book and Elena like cheated
on her husband and they had this
precious like and it's all she's ever
wanted now she's reneging on that one
she was like so certain and that's what
she wanted like I would have been like
[ __ ] you yeah and you know what I think
that the the show being released weekly
is really a mistake because it's not
that good like if we weren't recapping
it for the toast I would have stopped
probably last week if they had just
released it all at once like I would
have just finished it for the sake of
finishing a show like I just don't think
it's good enough to hold on to the
weekly system yeah I agree and that's
that on that that's that on that okay
are we doing a toast movie tonight
because I know what I'm watching tonight
and I feel like people can join me or
they cannot like honestly I just have
been like hating the choice maybe of the
day because I have to stop watching One
Tree Hill and I just don't want to do
okay so I think people should watch One
Tree Hill with you if that's what they
want I will be watching high school need
to go to tonight because I watched High
School Musical one and I absolutely
adored it and now here's what I have to
say here's what I have to say about high
school means wait it's Jackie I have a
question before you have to say
something is it brought to you is it
brought to you by Robo killer you know
what that's funny that you say that I
accept that was literally what I was not
today it was brought to you by one more
killer I'm so really me cuz you know
what's a total buzzkill spam calls they
invade your space are super annoying if
they're the last thing you want to do it
well we've teamed up with Robo killer to
give you guys a solution to the growing
spam call problem and it is growing I
feel like in the last five years it's
gone out of control it's out of control
I don't get any calls that aren't spam
like and you know what's really
deceiving is getting a spam phone call
from a number that's like the same is
your phone number but one digit on that
stop spam calls for good they vote for
1.2 million spam phone numbers on their
block list adding more spammers by the
minute in the month of February alone
Robo killer blocked over 17 million spam
calls we both recently downloaded Robo
killer on our phones and we are loving
it we just forget that it's there
because we're stopping getting spam
calls we can't tell you how many spam
calls and texts that we used to get I
must have one gotten like 10 free
cruises and like 45 trips to Disneyland
we are living fam free and getting sweet
revenge in the process they have
pre-recorded answer box that mess with
the spam callers for you which are
absolutely hilarious they're literally
like spam fighting assistants our
personal favorites are the jellyfish and
the southern cat lady if you don't want
spam callers cramming your Friday energy
get rowboat killer head to Robo killer
dot-com slash toast on your mobile
device now to download the app new users
get Robo killer free for seven days now
get out there and stop those spammers
again that's Robo killer dot-com at MIT
ok I'm so hungry so it let's just get
right into it I'm so hungry and honestly
like being in quarantine during Passover
is making life so difficult because
before this all I ate was mac and cheese
and just pasta and I can't eat it during
Passover until Thursday we have like
three more days until we can eat bread
and I want to die it's so difficult Wow
I think I need a brow lift
look at this missing this hold on look
hi Ella hadid mi Bella Hadid
Wow I think I need a lash lift
hmm I would like my hear what people
think about lash lifts do it after the
cable okay here's my thoughts on HSN one
I know we all joke like justice for
shar-pei
and you know what I have to be honest
like no justice for shar-pei like she is
not a nice person
um the person who's actually the villain
of HSM one is Chad
Troy's friend he is like such a
non-supportive friend he is a man who
does not support other men like he's
always he's just constantly trying to
push his agenda on to Troy and like he
doesn't care about Troy's happiness at
all and like at least Sharpay like we
know her intentions and her motives and
she's looking out for number one but
like chad is pretending to be Troy's
friend while only looking out for
himself and the basketball team
that's a were me the absolute goat on
High School Musical one is Miss Doris if
you really watch the movie
she is just everything like she's so
dramatic like it's so funny she's so
funny like everything that she says is
just like dripping with drama department
like it's so [ __ ] hilarious now I
watched High School Musical the musical
the series because snitch kept telling
me to and she said the music was good
and I have to say it's actually really
good I'm just so confused because I
don't know who it's for cuz it's more
it's not Disney child it's Disney Plus
and it's not for the Disney Channel set
because there's a little too much like
like weight and snark and I feel like
the kids wouldn't pick up on it it
really reminds me of Glee like it's
literally Glee even like just the way
they talk they have these like funny
confessionals it's actually really good
I mean obviously the protagonist is the
worst me um the girl like so they the
premise is they go to the high school
these kids are in high school and it's a
high school where high school musical
was shot but they've never done high
school musical to play at the high
school
so this drama teacher comes in and she
reminds me of a combination of Kristin
Chenoweth and Emma Pillsbury that's
exactly who she is put them together you
got this drama teacher and she's
actually she's obviously weird but she's
very sweet and she's a good teacher
um and so like this cast of Miss
it's like does their high school musical
production and its really good the music
is good um obviously the people like
there's two people who are so talented
Courtney and the girl who plays miss
darbus like she's a teenager but she's
probably starving the musical and she is
just like I'm amazing yeah um if you're
interested at all in watching it I would
recommend it for sure you know it's so
funny because I started this quarantine
like desperate for content and now that
I have something like I'm so closed off
like I just can't take on anything else
there's nine seasons I'm only on season
I'm about to be on season four like I
just and I really want to give this show
like my all I'm like so invested like I
have dreams about it like I'm so in one
tree hill like I basically live in North
Carolina Wow oh you know what else I saw
is out money heist the new season I
actually watch the first three seasons
and it's really good it's it's so so
good if you haven't watched it like I
would totally start it um it will get
you through and like it's really
compelling and I'll just you'll get
right into it it's exactly where you
want to be so I mean it's sad to only
have one season to watch but I will
definitely be watching that this week
and we are recording the redheads on
Wednesday and I still haven't started
the book you guys everyone including
Snitch everyone is finishing it in one
day so you should start it's called
before we were strangers by Renee Carly
know everyone is absolutely loving it
snitch said that she was sobbing like
the reviews are rave um
now is the perfect time to become a
redhead we've moved quarantine episodes
to two episodes a month so the next
episode will drop on Thursday and if you
like ever we're interested in reading a
book joining a book club listening to
another teen on podcast like the
redheads is eight you will love my
friends we have such a good time and
there's really something for everyone
because we all have different
personalities
it's fabulous and I do love Jackie's
friends so I think you will too great
okay well that's oh look there's gonna
be new episodes all week of no new TNN
show so Margaret Joseph's Olivia
snatchler mood with Lorne Elizabeth
Raven and Alexis I think have a new
episode today so make sure you're
following toast news network on
Instagram and please follow the morning
toast on Instagram we are almost at
200,000 we are at 197 and that'll just
be so cool so please follow at the
morning just do it also follow me at
Jackie O problems um you know what I've
been thinking about recently because
I've been working on my new presets for
a while now if you look at my flow right
now it's kind of different than like my
old flow because I have a new vibe
coming so I think there's gonna be like
some preset sales coming up so stay
tuned for that
um it's just gonna be fun our spring
merch store is closed so I hope you got
what you wanted and I can't wait till
you guys start receiving it I mean get
photos thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free from
web excuse me to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found too that Spotify iTunes stitcher
Public Radio I Heart Radio cash box all
the places so ever you listen to podcast
find us the morning toast I leave a
beautiful five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are we
love you guys so much we will see you
back tomorrow have a great day
stay safe bye